in 2009 I bought a house in Detroit for
$500 had no windows no plumbing no
electricity and it was filled with trash
the first floor held nearly 10,000
pounds garbage that included the better
part of a Dodge Caravan cut into chunks
with the reciprocating saw
I lived nearly two years without heat
woke up out of a dead sleep multiple
times two gunshots I was attacked by a
pack of wild dogs and ripped my kitchen
cabinets from an abandoned school as
they were actively tearing that school
down this of course is the Detroit that
you hear about you make no mistake it's
real
but there's another Detroit to another
Detroit that's more hopeful or
innovative and may just provide some of
the answers to city struggling to
reinvent themselves everywhere these
answers however do not necessarily
adhere to conventional wisdom about bid
development
I think Detroit's real strength boils
down to two words radical neighborliness
and I wasn't able to see it myself until
I lived there about a decade ago I moved
to Detroit with no friends no job and
the money at a time it seemed like
everyone else was moving out between
2000 and 2010 25% of the city's
population left us included about half
of the elementary age children this was
after six decades of decline a city
built for almost two million was down to
less than 800,000 what you usually don't
hear is that people didn't go very far
the population of the Detroit metro area
itself has largely remained steady since
the 70s most people who left Detroit
just went to the suburbs
well the 139 square miles of the city
deteriorated leaving
some estimates as high as 40 square
miles of abandoned land about the size
of San Francisco aside from platitudes
such as the vague and agentless
deindustrialization Detroit's exodus can
be summed up with two structures
freeways and walls the freeways coupled
with massive governmental subsidies for
the suburbs via infrastructure and home
loans a lot of people to leave the city
at will taking with it tax based jobs
and education dollars the walls made
sure only certain people could leave in
multiple places brick and concrete walls
separate city and suburbs white and
black running directly across municipal
streets and through neighborhoods their
mere physical manifestations of races
housing practices such as redlining
restrictive covenants and outright
terror in 1971 Ku Klux Klan Bob 10
school buses rather than have them
transport integrated students all these
have made Detroit the most racially
segregated metro area in the United
States I grew up in a small town in
Michigan the son of a relatively
blue-collar family and after University
I wanted to do something probably
naively to help I didn't want to be one
of the almost 50% of college graduates
leaving the state at the time and I
thought I might use my fancy college
education at home for something positive
I've been reading this great American
philosopher named Grace Lee Boggs who
happened to live in Detroit and she said
something I can't forget the most
radical thing that I ever did was to
stay put
I thought buying a house might indelibly
tie me to the city while acting as a
physical protest to these walls and
freeways because grants and loans
weren't available to everyone I decided
I was going to do this without them and
then I would wage my personal fight
against the city that had loomed over my
childhood with power tools I eventually
found an abandoned house in a
neighborhood called pol town
it looked like the apocalypse had
descended the neighborhood was
Prairieland a huge open expanse of waste
high grass cluttered only by handful a
crippled up abandoned Hut structures and
a few brave holdouts with well-kept
homes just a 15-minute bike ride from
the baseball stadium downtown the
neighborhood was positively rural what
houses were left look like cardboard
boxes left in the rain two-story
monstrosities with wide-open shells and
melted porches one of them of striking
things I remember where the rose bushes
forgotten and running wild over
tumbledown fences no longer cared for by
anyone this is my house on the day I
boarded it up protected from the
elements of further decay I eventually
purchased it from the county in a live
auction and assumed the neighborhood was
dead that I was some kind of pioneer
well I couldn't have been more wrong I
was in no way a pioneer and would come
to understand how offensive that is one
of the first things I learned was to add
my voice to the chorus not overwrite
what was already happening because the
neighborhood hadn't died it had just
transformed in a way that was difficult
to see if you didn't live there pol town
was home to incredibly resourceful
incredibly intelligent and incredibly
resilient community it was there I first
experienced the power of radical
neighborliness during the ER I worked on
my house before moving in I lived in a
micro community inside pol town founded
by a wild and virtuous farmer named Paul
woods Paul was a teacher in a detroit
public school for pregnant and parenting
mothers and his idea was to teach the
young women to raise their children by
first raising plants and animals while
the national average graduation rate for
pregnant teens is about 40% at Katherine
Ferguson Academy it was often above 90
in part due to Paul's ingenuity Paul
brought much of this innovation to his
block in Poletown which he'd stewarded
for more than 30 years purchasing houses
when they were abandoned convincing his
friends to move in and neighbors to stay
and helping those who wanted to buy
their own
fix them up in a neighborhood where many
blocks now only hold one or two houses
all the homes on Paul's block stand its
incredible testament to the power of
community to staying in one place and to
taking ownership of one's own
surroundings so simply doing it yourself
it's the kind of place where black
doctors live next to white hipsters next
to immigrant mothers from hungry or
talented writers from the jungles of
Belize showing me Detroit wasn't just
black and white and diversity could
flourish when it's encouraged each year
neighbors assembled to bale hay for the
farm animals on the Block teaching me
just how much a small group of people
can get done when they work together and
the magnetism of fantastical get
practical ideas radical neighborliness
is every house behind Paul's block
burning down and instead of letting it
fill up with trash and despair Paul and
the surrounding community creating a
giant circular garden rings with dozens
of fruit trees beehives and garden plots
for anyone that wants one helping me see
that our challenges can often be assets
it's where residents are experimenting
with renewable energy in urban farming
and offering their skills and
discoveries to others illustrating we
don't necessarily have to beg the
government to provide solutions we can
start ourselves it's where four months
one of my neighbors left her front door
unlocked in one of the most violent and
dangerous cities in America so I could
have a shower whenever I needed to go to
work as I didn't yet have one it was
when it came time to raise the beam on
my own house that holds the structure
aloft a beam that I cut out of an
abandoned recycling factory down the
street when a single wall was left
standing a dozen residents of Poletown
showed up to help lift it Amish style
radical neighborliness is a zygote that
grows into a worldview that ends up in
Homes and Communities rebuilding ways to
respect humanity in the environment it's
realizing we have the power to create
the world anew together and to do it
ourselves when our governments refuse
this is the Detroit that you don't hear
much about the Detroit between the ruin
porn on one hand and the hipster coffee
shops and billionaires saying
city on the other there's a third way to
rebuild and it declines to make the same
mistakes of the past while building my
house I found something I didn't know I
was looking for what a lot of
Millennials and people who are moving
back to cities are looking for radical
neighborliness is just another word for
true community the kind bound by memory
and history mutual trust and familiarity
built over years and irreplaceable and
now as you may have heard Detroit is
having a renaissance and pulling itself
up from the ashes of despair and the
children and grandchildren of those who
fled or returning which is true what
isn't true is that this renaissance is
reaching most Detroiters or even more
than a small fraction of them that don't
live in the central area as the city
these are the kind of people that have
been in Detroit for generations and are
most of black in 2016 alone just last
year one in six houses in her in Detroit
had their water shut off
excuse me the United Nations has called
this a violation of Human Rights and
since 2005 one in three houses think
about this police one in every three
houses has burnt been foreclosed in the
city representing a population about the
size of Buffalo in New York one in three
houses foreclosed
is not a crisis personal responsibility
is systemic
many Detroiters myself included our word
segregation is now returning to the city
itself on the coattails of this
Renaissance ten years ago it was not
possible to go anywhere in Detroit MP in
a crowd completely made of white people
now troublingly that is possible this is
the price that we're paying for
conventional economic resurgence we're
creating to Detroit's two classes of
citizens cracking the community apart
for all the money and subsidies for all
the street lights installed the dollars
for a new stadium
and slick advertisements and positive
buzz were shutting off water to tens of
thousands of people living right on the
great lakes the world's largest source
of it separate has always meant unequal
this is great mistake for all of us when
economic development comes the cost of
community it's not just those who have
lost their homes or access to water who
are harmed but it breaks little pieces
of our own humanity as well none of us
can truly be free none of us can truly
be comfortable until our neighbors are -
for those of us coming in it means we
must make sure we are inadvertently
contributing to the destruction of
community again and to follow the lead
of those who have been working on these
problems for years in Detroit that means
average citizens deputizing themselves
to create water stations and deliveries
for those who have lost access to it or
clergy and teachers engaging in civil
disobedience to block water shut-off
trucks its organizations buying back
foreclosed homes for their inhabitants
or fighting misinformation on for sales
through social media and volunteer run
hotlines for me it means helping others
to raise the beams on their own formerly
abandoned houses or helping to educate
those with privilege now increasingly
moving into cities how we might comments
in and support rather than stress
existing communities it's chipping in
what a small group of neighbors decides
to buy back a foreclosed home and return
the deeds to the occupants for you for
all of us it means finding a role to
play in our own communities it means
living your life as a reflection of the
world that you want to live in it means
trusting those who know the problems
best the people who live them with
solutions I know
a third way as possible because how I
have lived it I lived it I live it
excuse me I live it right now in a
neighborhood called pol town and one of
the most maligned cities in the world if
we can do it in Detroit you can do it
wherever you're from - what I've learned
over the last decade building my house
wasn't so much about wiring or plumbing
or carpentry although I did learn these
things is that true change real change
starts first with community with a
radical sense of what it means to be a
neighbor turned at least one abandoned
house into a halt thank you
[Applause]